[Música]
qué es el acuerdo de parís el 12 de
diciembre de 2015 195 países sellan el
primer acuerdo climático universal
china y eeuu los dos mayores
contaminadores ven por primera vez la
lucha contra el calentamiento global
supervisada por francia y la onu la
mejor oportunidad que tenemos de salvar
el planeta aseguró el entonces
presidente barack obama esto fue lo que
se decidió limitar el aumento de
temperaturas muy por debajo de dos
grados centígrados incluso a 1,5 grados
reduciendo nuestras emisiones de co2
cada país hizo promesas voluntarias y no
vinculantes un mundo neutro en carbono
de aquí a finales de siglo en resumen
que la cantidad de co2 emitida por las
actividades humanas sea igual a la
absorbida naturalmente por los árboles
suelos y océanos
también se prometieron 100 mil millones
de dólares por año para 2021 con el fin
de ayudar a los países más pobres un
compromiso también de reunirse cada 5
años para hacerlo mejor desde entonces
las emisiones han seguido aumentando
eeuu abandonó el acuerdo y la pandemia
de kobe 19
sido una distracción pero en 2021 de los
países podrían volver a unirse por el
clima gracias al impulso dado por el
electo presidente de eeuu y la prueba
clara de que el acuerdo de parís sigue
siendo la mejor oportunidad para
defender el planeta